konichiwa
right on schedule
[Music]
Deer Creek International Business
Solutions how can I help you I am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh I see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck really
bad luck is biblical I'm not even trying
to kill people when someone dies I
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
and he didn't die okay the wedding
tequila
Johannesburg it's time for some change
do you want it simple for your first job
back doesn't get simpler
we need to find a person who took that
case
it's too easy [__] what remember those
two wackos from the oblivious job the
twins yeah and I'll show you their twins
get off the train
you stabbed me
what
I missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man I've ever seen
really you don't remember me
[Music]
this lady I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm I'm
working on it get off at the next stop
it's so sweet easy when you say it one
little prick from this you know what
happens yes your blood congeal
s
you're going to want to hear the whole
story it's waiting for us in Kyoto the
white death with his army of Assassins
there's this solar psychotic leader with
the largest criminal organization on the
planet shut right inside
see the white death letting any of us
off this train
we need to come up with a plan
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma Maybe
[Music]
that's strange
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters